und sie selber ich habe sie eben gerade
eingeführt und vorgestellt
Berufsfeuerwehrmann aus Nürnberg
m die hab auch gesagt sie sie mussten da
nicht hin sie wollten das
warum also das so eine Invasion geht mit
so viel menschlichen leidern her dass
ich das nicht einfach angucken kann und
dann haben wir auch noch so ein Konflikt
der so so groß ist mit solchen
quantitativen Massen wie man es
möglicherweise seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg nicht mehr gesehen hat und das
das steht gegen alles was wir seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg erreicht haben wie ich
das sehe also es geht gegen die
internationale Ordnung es geht gegen die
also wo auch die Menschenrechte der UN
mit dabei sind und das geht gegen
Freiheit gleicher Demokratie es ist
einfach es ist einfach völlig falsch und
da muss man irgendwas machen da konnte
ich nicht einfach zugucken und dann als
ich da in Thailand war habe ich dann sie
waren in Thailand als sie von diesen von
dem Überfall von dem angriffagt ich war
in Thailand und hab dann hab dann
mitgekriegt wie es losging in der Früh
und einige Tage später habe ich dann in
in belgorot an der Grenze gesehen wo er
gesagt hat in diese Richtung V geht's in
den Donbass und da geht's nach hakev die
Russland sagt es geht in den Donbass
aber die Panzer fahren jetzt schon seit
20 Minuten nach hakev und das war einer
der Augenblicke wo ich dann entschieden
habe wo ich mir dachte da ist so wird so
viel Leid geben weil die Ukrainer werden
da nicht aufgeben da war ich mir ganz
sicher und da war für mich klar ich muss
irgendwas machen mus dann dorthin ja und
darf noch mal fragen weil ich das auch
gerade selbst erlebt habe und hat nicht
mit dem zu tun was sie da erlebt haben
äh uns ging es auch um etwas anderes ja
uns ging es darum auch mal zu
dokumentieren dass Krieg so unendlich
viel mehr ist als tote Soldaten und
zerstörte Gebäude ja darum zu zeigen wie
sich wie sich Misstrauen und auch Angst
in so eine Gesellschaft langsam
reinfrisst und was das wirklich mit mit
mit Familien und vor allem auch mit
Kindern macht aber sie jetzt ich ich
erändere dieses Gefühl dann überquerst
du nachts plötzlich diese Grenze da
sträuben sich an dem alle Nackenhaare
ging ihn das auch so das ging mir auch
so also ich bin über die Grenze gefahren
in die Ukraine und ich hatte alleine ich
bin alleine gefahren also ich kam aus
Thailand hatte hatte über eine kleine
NGO den Kontakt zur Feuerwehr erhalten
hatte dann ein Interview mit dem General
dort als ich diese Information hatte bin
ich nach Deutschland geflogen haben mir
ein Auto gekauft B los gefahren auf der
anderen Seite also direkt am
Grenzübergang hatte ich das Gefühl ich
bewege mich auf etwas zu während mein
ganzer Körper eigentlich wegdrückt DAV
richtig und ich bin dann über diese
Grenze gefahren und da war eine Handvoll
Autos in meine Richtung reinwärts und
gefühlt 20 km Stau in die andere
Richtung Menschen auf der Flucht
Menschen auf der Flucht und ich bin dann
mit bin dann gefahren hat eine
Tankstelle gesucht und es war praktisch
jede Tankstelle ohne Benzin es war
vielleicht jede achte Tankstelle das
hier im Hintergrund ist üens eine
Tankstelle ne das war Maline Tankstelle
wenn man ner an die Front kommt sehen
die Tankstellen so aus die ersten sieht
man vor Kier wenn man Richtung Kier
fährt dann sehen die ersten irgendwann
so aus ET 30 km vorher wenn man dann
weiterkommt also beispielswe we von hkif
weiter in den Osten fährt sehen sehr
viele Tankstellen so aus ich bin im
Prinzip von der Grenze Zickzack bis nach
hkev gefahren das hat vier Tage gedauert
und immer mit
der das ist ja es ist ja das ist ja eine
wirklich eine Reise auch ins also in
wirklich in die Dunkelheit in den
Abgrund wenn man so will der Westen wo
man sich noch vergleichsweise sicher
fühlt aber ich habe gelernt es gibt
keinen wirklich sicheren Ort in der
Ukraine auch in in leviv können Sie
Menschen treffen 12jähri getreffen die
dann beim Besuch auf dem Bahnhof einfach
plötzlich beide Beine verlieren und
plötzlich mit mit mit mit Beinprothesen
durchs Leben gehen müssen all solche
Dinge aber dann kommt man nach Kiev und
merkt dann plötzlich jetzt das ist Krieg
es ist ruhig es ist leise das ist die
Familie die wir da in leevv getroffen
haben und dann geht's immer weiter
Richtung Osten und man kann das spüren
es wird dunkel man hat ständig diesen
Alarm auf dem Telefon und man kriegt ein
Gefühl dafür wie nah das plötzlich alles
ist wo wo wo wo wo sind sie zuerst
angekommen also ich kam zunächst also
ich bin nach HF gefahren ich also vor
hier hat ich meine ersten da waren die
ersten Panzer gestanden zerschossenen
auf der Straße das war ein komisches
Gefühl aber es war nicht mehr dieses
Gefühl als als als ich über die Grenze
bin wo ich wirklich den hier hatte nach
nach einem Tag war das schon ein
bisschen bisschen weniger sehr komisch
war es wie ich dann in HIF ankam es war
man hatte auf diese hollywoodszenen im
Kopf mit mit und und Explosionen überall
aber es war gar nicht so es war die es
war dämmernd es war leise es war fast
still es waren sämtliche straßenlaten
ausgeschalten es gab keine Lichter in
den Fenstern genau Fenster waren kaputt
Fenster verschalt immer mal wieder ein
Dach zerstört und alle 20 Minuten ein
riesiger Intervall Artillerie Bam Bam
Bam Bam Pam Pam Pam Pam 2 Minuten Pause
das gleiche noch mal und dann wieder
Pause und das war das war sehr
unheimlich also eine menschenlehere
statt m mit viel Zerstörung und immer
wieder Artillerie also im Hintergrund
und sie sind dann auch selber unter
Beschuss geraten wir haben immer einen
Teil dieser Bilder gesehen aber wenn man
das von Anfang an sieht dann dann sieht
man dass sie auch da da passiert
wirklich ganz nahe und hochgefährlich
für Sie was war das für eine Situation
das war so der der Wirten Einsatz hat
das Telefon geklingelt das es gab ein
Artillerieangriff wir sind dann zu dem
vorerr nach dem Artillerieangriff
gefahren hatten das Haus dann praktisch
abgelöscht waren fertig mit der Arbeit
wollten zusammen zusammenräumen in dem
Augenblick ist dann ein weiterer
Beschuss erfolgt wir sind erst runter
man sieht das bei dem bei dem Kollegen
eben wir sind wir sind runter einer der
Kollegen ist eben wahrscheinlich nicht
rechtzeitig weggekommen das ist der den
wir jetzt gerade hier am im Bild sehen
den hatten wir dann mit
schrabnellverletzungen ins Krankenhaus
gebracht also erst ins Auto so verbracht
und dann mit Verletzungen ins erste
Krankenhaus das hat der hat das
überstanden der hat's überstanden er ist
dann grob zusammengefflickt worden in
diesem ersten Feldlazarett das ist
meistens zwischen roter und gelber Zone
irgendwo da wird man grob zusammengebaut
damit man das überlebt und dann geht's
in das richtige Krankenhaus weiter und
er hat überlebt den habe ich dann später
auch in Kirf getroffen noch mal also bin
ich ins Krankenhaus gefahren hat hat er
auch tatsächlich einen Splitter in den
Kopf gekriegt den hat er aber überlebt
mhm Fred pleitken sagt so wie wir dort
unter Beschuss geraten auch als Reporter
habe ich das vorher nie erlebt nee habe
ich ja nicht er aber man muss sagen hier
was was was der nilstal erlebt hat das
ist glaube ich noch mal eine Ecke
schlimmer weil was man was man bei bei
den First responders bei den
Feuerwehrleuten nämlich wissen muss ist
dass die ja auch gezielt angegriffen
werden das nennt sich double tap die
Methode da schießen die auf irgendwas
drauf warten bis die Helfer ankommen und
schießen dann noch mal drauf das habe
ich einmal erlebt in kamatorsk da hatten
sie eine Rakete geschossen Krankenhaus
dann kamen die ganzen Helfer und dann
sind wieder angekommen und auf einmal
landeten zwei weitere Raketen und das
ist natürlich die sind natürlich dann
sozusagen weiches Ziel weil die Leute ja
alle draußen sind versuchen zu helfen
und dann schlägt eine Rakete ein und
versucht die dann halt noch mal ganz
bewusstor ganz bewusst ob die versuchen
dann noch mehr Leute zu erledigen keine
Ahnung aber es verbreitet auf jeden Fall
Terror das ist auf jeden Fall eine
schlimme Sache aber was was man halt
sich immer vor Augen führen muss das hat
man jetzt auch gerade in in dem Video
gesehen ist dass dort einfach mit viel
schwer Waffen gekämpft wird und mit
einer viel größeren Anzahl davon als bei
bei allem was wir in den letzten Jahren
erlebt haben wenn man sich anguckt in
Irak und Afghanistan da ist man auch in
Feuergefechte reingeraten teilweise auch
mit ein bisschen schweren Waffen aber
Luftangriffe Angriffe mit riesigen
Raketen die dafür da sind teilweise die
in der Lage sind Atomwaffen zu tragen
die dann zwar einen konventionellen
Sprengstoff drauf haben weil der
irgendwie 600 oder 700 kg Sprengstoff
drin hat der vernichtet halt ein ganzen
Häuserblock ne und das ist einfach eine
ganz andere Nummer und wenn man sich
anguckt in der Nähe von diesen
Schützengräben oder in den
Schützengräben die sitzen da drin und
die werden die ganze Zeit davon
beschossen und ich frag mich auch wie
die da nicht verrückt werden drin weil
da kannst das kann natürlich dann auch
jederzeit ganz ganz schnell zu Ende
gehen und und ähm man lernt dann auch
schnell also also wie wie Sie
wahrscheinlich auch dass wenn wenn du da
bist und du hörst das Pfeifen von der
artillerieegranate dann hast du eine
Sekunde um auf dem Boden zu kommen und
wenn du nicht auf dem Boden kommst dann
bist du erledigt es gab einen ganz
schlimmen Vorfall vor dem letzten wo ich
in wo der Ukrain war ist ein ähm ein ich
glaub ein Fotograf von von der Agentur
AFP der war ein der Gruppe unterwegs ähm
da sind die alle schnell genug auf dem
Boden gekommen er offenbar nicht und ist
dann auch ums Leben gekommen das geht so
das geht so und man ist weg greift man
auch gezieht reporterteams an
Journalisten an es teilweise vielleicht
also ich ich kann nicht sagen dass ich
dafür jetzt
exorbitant viele Beweise hätte aber es
ist es ist ein mal wo ich nicht ernst
natür nicht aber ich meine ich war auch
in der freont Nähe aber es ist einfach
so dass auf alles geschossen wird es ist
so dass einfach mit einer riesigen
Anzahl von Geschossen auf alles
geschossen wird und wer auch immer da
ist der wird dann halt erledigt und das
ist dann oft Zivilisten sind natürlich
dann auch Soldaten aber da da da geht's
extrem zur Sache und zwar die ganze Zeit
mhm als wir in herson während der
Evakuierungen waren sind wir ebenfalls
unter Beschuss geraten und da waren die
Presse Tretter häufig an den
Evakuierungszonen gestanden und dort
wurde dann eben auch beschossen also wir
waren gerade draußen und dann haben wir
mitgekriegt dass draußen
Artilleriebeschuss herrscht oder ein
panzerbeschuss wahrscheinlich und das
war auch direkt in unmittelbarer Nähe
von den von den von den Reportern das
ist durchaus möglich dass das sie haben
auch die Überflutung ne von HoN ich war
auch in in HoN mitgekriegt als der große
Staudamm gesprengt wurde wie wie haben
sie das
erlebt sie haben es geschildert dieser
Geruch von Tod und Verwesung der geht ih
nicht mehr aus der Nase also das ist
also ich war ich war ich war vorher in
konstantinfka bei bachmut wollte
eigentlich weiter nach als die
ukrainischen Truppen langsam die Russen
zurückgedrängt haben wollte ich
eigentlich nach kopjansk weiter weil das
der nächste Hotspot war der defensiv
Hotspot und ich sitze Sitze in dem
Augenblick in Kiev in der Früh kriegen
Anruf von von demem Reporter meint so
bist du schon in kupion da habe ich
gesagt nein ich bin gerade in Kiev hab
mir einen Kaffee rausgelassen hat er
gemand hast du Nachrichten gelesen habe
ich gesagt noch nicht gemeintt mach das
ich habe dann die Nachrichten angemacht
und hab dann diese Bilder gesehen und
dann war ich im Prinzip unterwegs nach
heronn bin dann da mitternachts
angekommen und am nächsten Tag direkt in
die in die
Evakuierungsmaßnahmen mit sind sind ihre
Bilder hier ne haben dann Häuser
evakuiert alte Menschen rausgeholt exakt
ja wir haben Häuser evakuiert wir haben
alte Menschen Häuser evakuiert alte
Menschen evakuiert und Häuser auch
kontrolliert das wollte auch nicht jeder
aus dem Haus raus da haben wir dann im
Prinzip auch auch Versorgung gebracht
also wir haben dann Wasser gebracht wir
haben wir haben Medikamente gebracht
hier haben wir jetzt an einen von den
Patienten gehabt ich hatte immer mal
wieder mein Handy hier zum zum einfach
zum dokumentieren auch mit dabei diese
Person konnte nicht mehr laufen die
hatte komplett starre Beine also
komplett verknöchert ja und der kam da
nicht raus den mussten wir dann
evakuieren im Prinzip und nach der Flut
als das dann alles weg war war eine
Schlammschicht gestanden auf der Straße
die gestunken hat mit verwenden Tieren
drinnen jetzt haben wir hier
gerade den Augenblick gehabt mit den
Boten wo sie angefangen haben zu
schießen sind wir gerade raus und dann
hat die russische Arme angefangen zu
schießen das hier ist jetzt was wir
jetzt gerade sehen ist mit den NGOs wo
wir dann auf die Dörfer auch raus sind
wo wir da ein bisschen den den die Flut
also es gab Dörfer die wenig Hilfe
abbekommen hatten also wo wenig
Möglichkeit war scheinbar für von der
offiziellen Struktur dort zu versorgen
das sind wir mit den Enos dann
rausgefahren und haben dann Wasser
wassermikamente Nahrungsmittel
rausgebracht und dort war auch die
Situation ziemlich prekär das sieht man
jetzt hier auf dem Bild das ist
wahrscheinlich Personen Stadt aber die
Dörfer den Fluss hoch und Fluss runter
und voren in dem seitenfluss sahen
ähnlich aus danach war auch das also
diese Existenzen diese Menschen haben in
ein Haus da steckt das ganze Leben
drinnen und danach ist dieses Haus
komplett zerstört mit allem was da
drinnen steckt und das habe ich beim
Rausfahren immer wieder mal miterlebt
leider und dann gibt's immer zwei Dinge
das habe ich dort so gesehen ist so Bee
dren zu sehen wie schnell die Ukraine
alles reparieren aber wenn man dann mit
Leuten dort in der Gegend spricht die
sagen weißt du es ist eine Sache das
jetzt wieder zu reparieren aber wann
kommen die wieder zurück und machen es
mir wieder kaputt das heißt da so eine
ungeheure Sinnlosigkeit auch drin in
gewisser Weise das macht die Menschen so
wahnsinnig müde und mürbe wenn uns mal
fredich Pleiten wie das vorhin auch
gerade sagte sie haben ja damals den den
Beginn dieses Krieges auf der anderen
Seite dokumentiert und ich habe diese
Bilder damals auch gesehen ähnlich wie
nilsal der in in in Thailand saß äh das
ist ja ens Genus genauso eine Situation
da stehst du vor diesem zerstörten
Bauernhaus
diese Familie hatte gerade auch neue
Maschinen gekauft und so weiter Schulden
gemacht dafür die waren noch nie im
Einsatz und dann ist das Frontlinie und
wird einfach komplett zerstört
ähm sie haben das von anderen Seite
erlebt wie haben sie sozusagen den den
den den Stimmungswechsel den es
möglicherweise gegeben hat wahrgenommen
also erstmal rein und die Idee in drei
Tagen haben wir das alles erledig haben
gedacht in drei Tagen ungefähr drei
Tagen aber das dachten die wirklich ja
das dachten die auf jeden Fall wirklich
weil sie haben gedacht dass ihre Armee
technisch weit überlegen war was sie
auch war aber nicht so weit wie Sie wie
Sie gedacht haben wir hat natürlich auch
einen großen Glauben an ihre eigene
Kriegsmaschinerie weil die Russen ja
auch eine zumindest auf dem Papier eine
Modernisierung ihrer Streitkräfte schon
seit seit vielen Jahren äh durchgeführt
haben auch der Luftwaffe was ich ja dann
auch irgendwie als als nicht so ganz
richtig rausgestellt war aberi len mal
dann viel Geld in dunklen Kanälen
vielleicht eh die Villa des modernisiert
wurde
die hatten ganz lange Schlangen von
gepanzerten Fahrzeugen viele Haubitzen
und Raketenwerfer die sie da in in
Stellung gebracht haben an der Grenze
und wir haben die dann gesehen wie die
mit ihren Panzern sich erst eingegraben
haben in Grenzregion und dann über die
Grenze rüber gefahren sind und
gleichzeitig hab man mal gesehen wie die
die Raketenwerfer da positioniert haben
und was uns aufgefallen ist also mir
meinem Team ist dass die am Anfang alle
gelacht haben die haben Victory Zeichen
gemacht als an unserer Kamera
vorbeigefahren sind vielleicht dachten
sie wir werens russische Fernsehen aber
egal die waren auf jeden Fall sehr guter
Dinge und nach ungefähr drei Tagen habe
ich gemerkt dass die immer öfter ihre
schusssicheren Westen in die Türen von
ihren LKWs reingetan haben was ein
Zeichen ist dass es gegenbeschuss gab
und dass es irgendwie doch nicht so toll
lief und
und die wohden dann auch immer
kratzbürstiger also an was war so da war
eine Bushaltestelle das war so der
letzte Ort wo man hin konnte da haben
wir uns dann hingestellt haben die dann
gefilmt haben dann dann live berichtet
von dort aus auch und da kam dann immer
öfter halt der Geheimdienst und hats
verscheucht und die wurden dann auch
immer unfreundlicher und da hat man
schon gemerkt dass da irgendwas nicht so
gut läuft und ich hatte gedacht ich
finde ja also ich find's ja unglaubl
dass nach hakev gefahren sind weil das
war zu dem Zeitpunkt super schwer
dahinzukommen weil die Russen sind ja
von Norden einmarschiert und von Osten
einmarschiert und und von süen auch
einmarschiert und man man schlängelte
sich damals so hin und her dass man
nicht irgendwie an die Front Gerät um um
nach hakev gerade zu kommen ich hatte
gedacht hakev ist auch innerhalb von
paar Tagen erledigt weil das ist eine
Stadt nah an der Grenze die Russen mit
dieser Übermacht die ich da gesehen habe
wenige Kilometer weg die die und die
Ukrainer haben die Russen da platt
gemacht wie groß ist HAK ist die glaub
ich die zweite größte Stadt der Ukraine
ne Millionen oder so ne weniger weniger
ungefähr zwischen Wien und
München so um mal Idee zu kriegen und
bevor wir gleich mit Florence gup
darüber sprechen würde ich sie auch noch
gerne fragen
heritin also für mich zum
deprimierendsten was ich erlebt habe
waren die Gespräche mit russischen
Kriegsgefangenen mit russischen Soldaten
und du verstehst irgendwann die diese
Leute werden ja dämonisiert und es ist
das das das das Böse schlecht hin äh und
dann fängt man auch an die Leute zu
entmenschlichen und das hört man auch
häufig in der Ukraine diese Bestien und
so weiter und es ist in der Tat
bestialisch was die gemacht haben aber
was man dann irgendwann auch versteht
ist Putin hat diesen Krieg nicht nur den
Ukrainern angetan er hat ih auch
Russland und den Russen angetan
ja würde ich zu dem in gewisser Weise
auch sagen aber nicht nur also Putin die
die der Rückhalt für den Krieg in
Russland der ist ja immer noch groß und
ich glaube da gibt's auch viele Leute
die das die nicht sehr enthusiastisch
sind über den Krieg die diesen Krieg
vielleicht auch ins geheim schlecht
finden aber sich nicht trauen irgendwas
zu sagen weil wenn da ein öffentliches
Meinungsforschungsinstitut hinkommt dann
würde ich auch den Teufel tun den die
Wahrheit zu sagen aber es gibt schon
viele Leute mit denen ich auch noch
Verkehre die zumindest hoffen dass
Russland gewinnt die wollen sich selbst
da nicht rein involvieren den ist es
aber okay wenn der Nachbar da da
irgendwie mitmacht aber das gibt's auch
ich glaube auf der russischen Seite gibt
es eine ganz große Bandbreite an Leuten
die da mitmachen es gibt ja diese diese
privaten Milizen was war vorher war die
jetzt aber auch in anderen von den
Streitkräften so ein bisschen
vereinnahmt wurden da sind ganz viele
die entweder aus wirtschaftlichen
Gründen weil sie keinen Job finden
irgendwo anders dahingen man kauft bei
bei der Armee z.B auch dann gibt's
Berufssoldaten auch von Spezialeinheiten
wie den Fallschirm das ist die
Luftlandetruppe das ist eine riesige
Gruppe fast wie die Marines bei den USA
da sind ganz viele das sind schon schon
professionelle Soldaten und dann gibt's
natürlich diese ganz ganz große Gruppe
von Leuten die eigentlich nur
Kanonenfutter sind GI dass der Begriff
den ich gehört habe die die aus dem
Knast jetzt rekrutiert werden und ich
war auch einmal dabei
in in der Frontnähe in der Nähe von Vica
no Silka da wollten wir mit dem
Kommandeur reden und der Befragte gerade
ein der aus im Knast re rekrutiert
worden war und das war wirklich also ein
ganz armer Tropf hat gesehen R wieder
vom Leben gezeichnet war kaum noch Zähne
und der hatte auch genau das was man so
bei uns so
Eigenverantwortung sieht oder oder so so
eine Idee von von Menschen und
bürgerrech das gab's da einfach nicht
also die haben gesagt warum warum hast
du den Vertrag untergeschrieben ja hat
mir der gesagt warum bist du hingekommen
er hat mir der und der gesagt warum
wolltest du uns umbringen hat mir der
und der gesagt das war die Antwort auf
fast da war nichts mit ich habe das
entschieden ich wollte das machen ne das
das das gibt's da natürlich aus aber ähm
ich glaube dass Putin der einzig
Verantwortliche für den Krieg ist glaube
ich nicht also es gibt schon sehr sehr
viele Russen die das auch mittragen mhm
ich ähm habe immer wieder gehört
gerade die die Männer die aus dem Knast
rekrutiert werden die kommen dann an mit
mit schon mit zwei Krankheiten an der
Front HIV positiv Tuberkulose das sind
sozusagen die die die beiden Krankheiten
die viele viele von denen mitbringen das
heißt die kommen in einem erbärmlichen
Zustand da an die sind die sind
geschwächt Menschen die 3 Jahre alt sind
die du triffst sehen aus wie Mitte 50
oder oder Anfang 60 und haben im Grunde
nichts zu verlieren und einer erzählte
ja dem Film auch gerade zu sehen wir
sind mit 200 man da rein und kam zurück
ja das das war gerade in bachmut
Ende letzten Jahres Anfang diesen Jahres
war das war das krass also habe ich auch
mit
mit Ukrainern gesprochen die das die auf
der ander Seite davon standen also die
das Abwehren mussen und die haben gesagt
die
Waren in dem Schützengraben die waren
mit 20 Mann Meinweg und da kam auf
einmal 200 Russen an und die sind
einfach über ein offenes Feld
dahinestürmt die ersten Gruppen haben
sie alle niedergemäht und die haben auch
gesagt die hatten ungefähr haben auch
ungefähr 200 gezählt haben gesagt haben
ungefähr 160 von denen umgebracht und
mussten am Ende dann aber auch sich
zurückziehen weil das einfach immer mehr
von diesen menschlichen Wellen war und
das das ist schon schon echt heftig wie
die dann einfach da als Kanonenfutter re
reingeschickt wuren dieen das teilweise
auch so gemacht dass die dann so die die
die Leute aus dem Knast oder andere arme
Leute als Kanonenfutter vorschicken und
dann ihre eigenen Spezialeinheiten
versuchen da da hinterher reinzusicken
und dann die Ukrainer in die Zange zu
nehmen dass man sozusagen so ein
menschliches Schild hat und auch jetzt
im Süden wo die Ukrainer so große
Schwierigkeiten hatten durchzukommen
wegen den Minenfeldern da war vor diesen
Minenfeldern auch oft eine Front quasi
an Kanonenfutter an an Typen die aus dem
Knast waren die S hingemacht das war so
die erste Linie und danach kam erst die
die Minenfelder und vorstellbar das ist
schon echt heftig also was da sehen wir
das auch ne das sind so so diese
typischen Schilder die man da überall
sieht jemand sagte mir se das am meisten
vermiente Gebiet der Welt gibt nirgendwo
auf der Welt solche Dichte an Minen
landmen die man finden kann ja man sagt
auf der Südfront ist die Zahl die ich
gehört habe da von den Leuten and der
Südfront ungefähr dre Minen pro
Quadratmeter vorstellbar Florence gaup
sagt die Russen und darüber haben uns
auch in der Sendung schon mal
unterhalten haben ein anderes Verhältnis
zum Tod zu Zerstörung
[Musik]
zu Gewalt ein Armeesprecher in Kiev
sagte mir das eine Kultur des Todes
würden Sie dem zustimmen würden sie es
auch so drastisch ausdrücken
ähm ich würde vor allem sagen dass ich
glaube dass wir als als als Westeuropäer
den den Bezug zur Gewalt und zum Tod
komplett verloren haben bzw ist als
etwas ganz unnatürliches begreifen ne
und natürlich wir haben auch schon mal
über Russland geredet aber man kann auch
andere Länder hinzufügen ja in USA
sterben 40.000 Menschen pro Jahr durch
private Waffengewalt der islamische
Staat hat in Syrien im Irak also mit
unglaublicher Gewalt also nicht mal hier
haben wir quantitativ der islamische
Staat aber auch Hamas was sie jetzt
gerade in is gemacht haben geht darum
dass man so richtig also so so eine Art
von so nicht es geht nicht nur darum
umzubringen sondern so richtig wie genau
Sprache Gewalt ist eine Sprache und ich
würde sagen dass hier in in Westeuropa
wir haben keinen Militärdienst mehr
Gewalt gegen Kinder Gewalt in der Ehe
Vergewaltigung in der Ehe ist jetzt ein
Straftatbestand also die Liste geht ewig
weiter seit den 90er Jahren ist
eigentlich so bei uns ist Gewalt und Hal
Verlängerung Tod dementsprechend ist was
was es bei uns eigentlich ist böse und
git gar nicht mehr gleichzeitig was ganz
interessantes geht aber die Zahl von
gewalttätigen Video spielen oder auch
Fernsehsendungen oder Filmen immer
weiter nach oben also deswegen was ich
sage ist irgend wie und ich habe es auch
nicht raus aber irgendwie gehört Gewalt
zum menschlichen Leben dazu wir mit
unserer postmodernen Einstellung wissen
nicht ganz genau wohin damit also räumen
wir es jetzt mal in den in den in den in
den künstlichen Raum aber was ganz klar
ist Russland aber natürlich wie gesagt
auch andere Länder hat einen näheren
Bezug zur Gewalt und natürlich sieht man
auch jetzt in der russischen Militär was
gerade fr beschrieben hat diese diese ja
das Kanonenfutter das ist ja eigentlich
fast schon also sowjetisch also das war
ja im Zweiten Weltkrieg auch schon so
genau dass man einfach das was man an an
Qualität nicht hat wird dann durch
Quantität ersetztte und und wer
zurückgeweicht wird von den eigenen
Leuten erschossen ne das gab's ja dort
zumindest h ich hat man geh obwohl das
haben wir auch auch ja Leute von von der
wagnertruppe haben das auch erzählt dass
das so ist ich muss ich muss sagen bei
den Russen also ich habe ja dre Jahre
lang in Russland gelebt und ich hatte
die
im Nachhinein das das das Privileg also
es war schon schon gut um das mal kenn
ich habe jeden Sonntag
mit russischen Veteranen und generellen
und und auch aktiven eishhoockey
gespielt das sind ja genau die Typen die
jetzt da einen Krieg ziehen sollen und
die waren alle immer sehr freundlich
sehr zu vorkommen haben mir auch
geholfen wenn ich Hilfe brauchte aber es
ist da irgendwas als als dieser Krieg
losgegangen ist wo die dann einfach das
gemacht haben wo dann dann auch man da
auch nicht mehr drüber reden konnte dass
das dass das falsch ist und dass das ein
Verbrechen ist sowas zu machen anderes
Land überfallen das das war das hat mich
schon extrem verwundert also ich habe
jetzt immer noch viele Kontakte nach
Russland ich habe auch keinen ähm mit
dem ich in Russland Kontakt hatte oder
wo ich sagen würde ist in ein Bekannter
oder ein Freund ich habe mit keinem von
denen gebrochen wir haben auch immer
noch Kontakt wir reden nicht viel über
über die Moralität von dem ganzen was
los ist sondern mehr über das operative
wo sie gewonnen und verloren haben aber
es ist da schon irgendwas wo ich mich
gewundert habe warum das nicht mehr in
Frage gestellt wird das ist ein absolut
das ist gehört meines Erachtens ist das
also wir sagen ein Verhältnis zur Gewalt
aber auch ein Verhältnis dazu wer bin
ich als Staatsbürger welche Rechte habe
ich welche Pflichten habe ich als
Staatsbürger wie viel Eigenverantwortung
habe ich als Staatsbürger und da ist
glaube ich ganz viel wo wo diese Idee
von von
von wie heißt das bei uns die die Armee
von ja ja innere Führung aber auch die
die so ein
demokratischee Bürger in Uniform ist da
einfach nicht so aber ich ich würde
nicht sagen der Krieg ist jetzt passiert
weil Russland ein anderes Verhältnis zu
Gewalt hat Sonn ich glaube tatsächlich
auch dass für für viele Russen und aber
natürlich auch für die Regierung steht
tatsächlich was auf dem Spiel was
geopolitisch ist also für für also ich
da gab's auch eine Umfrage letztens ganz
interessant fast alle Russen oder nicht
fast alle aber eine große Mehrheit der
Russen ist immer noch für diesen Krieg
will dass die Ukraine ihn verliert teilt
aber nicht die Ansicht der Regierung
dass es bei diesem Krieg in der Ukraine
eigentlich um den Westen geht das ist ja
das was Putin und die Regierung sagt das
Teilen die nicht für die meisten Russen
geht es tatsächlich nur um die Ukraine
für Putin und die Regierung geht es aber
um einen größeren geopolitischen
Konflikt in dem die Vormachtstellung des
Westens jetzt endlich mal in Frage
gestellt werden soll das ist also für
uns ist das jetzt eigentlich eine
interessante Einsicht weil es würde
bedeuten dass die Regierung nicht so
weit gehen kann bzw nicht immer
weitermachen kann weil sie eventuell die
Unterstützung für alles was jetzt
vielleicht über die Ukraine
hinausgeht nicht so viel da ist und als
jemand der sich so viel auch mit mit
geostrat ischen Fragen beschäftigt wie
sie die Frage ist das denn erfolgreich
dieses narrativ diese Erzählung also wir
fordern jetzt ultimativ den Westen
heraus wir stellen sozusagen die
Machtfrage ich bin immer wieder
irritiert wenn ich dann sehe wer
plötzlich alles so mit Putin kuschelt
wer auf also was deswegen ist diese
Umfrage so interessant also bei
Stichwort was sagt man schon in Russland
einem russischen
meinungsumfrageinstitut aber wir sehen
natürlich das auf internationaler Ebene
ist dieses narrativ total erfolgreich
und das sieht man ja jetzt auch in dass
China und Russland sich auch tendenziell
tendenziell eher auf die Seite der Hamas
oder eher gegen Israel positioniert
haben und im sogenannten globalen Süden
wird natürlich den Westen vorgeworfen
Stichwort Irak Invasion des Irak genau
mega doppelte Standards während die
Russen machen das jetzt in der Ukraine
da stört es euch beim Irak hat's euch
nicht gestört euch stört jetzt plötzlich
der Angriff auf Israel aber irgendwie
dass die Palästinenser seit 70 Jahren
keinen Start haben das stört euch nicht
also das fällt bei vielen Staaten bei
vielen B Gang in vielen Staaten im
sogenannten globalen Süden auf
ruchtbaren Boden ja das ist ein Fakt das
heißt das hören sie auch wenn sie mit
Leuten spral ja also ich war war gerade
in den Emiraten also die Emirate war
waren ja eigentlich lange so ein eher
ein Partnerstaat für den Westen die
haben sich gerade in dieser Frage sehr
neutral verhalten und sie sind auch
nicht die einzigen also das ist schon
was eine eine Frage und wir können uns
auch jetzt nicht hinstellen und zu tun
als werden wir einfach moralisch
überlegen und die haben alle Unrecht
sondern vielleicht mal kurz pausieren
sagen okay woran könnte das liegen
vielleicht
mm hat auch der der der Sprecher von
Putin schon letztes Jahr im Juni gesagt
der peskov genau der hat mir gesagt dass
die fest davon überzeugt ist dass es
unmöglich ist Russland mit Sanktionen zu
isolieren die der hat damals schon
gesagt wir sind viel zu groß viel zu
viele Leute wollen unsere Rohstoffe
kaufen die Leute werden wiederkommen
wenn man jetzt sich z.B anguckt war das
letzte Treffen von den bricks staten da
wollten ja ganz viele Staaten auf einmal
dieser dieser Gruppe beitreten das ist
Brasilien Russland Indien China und
Südafrika wollen da treten ja nächstes
Jahr andere Staaten auch bei und andere
wollen da auch hin und inofern da gibt's
schon viele die weiter mit den Russen
Geschäfte machen wollen und und diesem
isolieren durch Sanktionen international
echten das funktioniert nicht genau aus
aus den Gründen ich glaube es gibt
gerade im sogenannten globalen Süden
ganz viele Leute die die dem Westen
Vorwürfen Jahre lang nicht die
Interessen der Bürger dieser Länder im
Auge gehabt zu haben vor allem wenn man
Irak angucken die nicht nur die Invasion
des Iraks sondern auch die vielen
grßwechsel die während dieser Invasion
und und und auch danach dieser Invasion
stadgefunden haben viele Leute glauben
dass das zum Nachteil der Bürger dort
gegangen ist und was was ich man mir in
Saudi-Arabien gesagt hat im
Außenministerium war wir sind natürlich
eher bei euch emotional aber zwingt uns
nicht zu wählen und ich glaube das ist
das Problem dass es war so ein bisschen
nach der nach dem überfä auf die Ukraine
war so seid Ihr mit uns oder gegen uns m
ganz viele also gerade im Golf die auch
viel handeln mit Russland haben gesagt
na ja
wir würden uns da eigentlich ganz gerne
raushalten und das ist jetzt noch der
arabische Raum wenn man nach Afrika
südlich der Sahara schaut dann ist es
schon eher sehr proorussisch